>>Female Presenter: So W. Scott Poole blames
repeated viewings of shock
theater at an impressionable age for his monster
obsession. Associate professor of history
at the College
of Charleston, he's also a prolific pop culture
critic. His reviews and commentary
can be found at popmatters.com, religiondispatches.com
and other sites. In addition to "Monsters
in America", his
other books include "Satan in America: the
devil we know".
And "Never Surrender: Confederate memory and
conservativism
in the South Carolina upcountry" which was
the 2004 winner
of the George C. Rogers Award for best book
on South Carolina history.
Poole lives in Charleston, South Carolina
with his partner Beth Phillips, two dogs,
an
extensive comic book and vinyl record collection.
Please help me to welcome Scott Poole.
[Applause]
>> Scott: Well thank you. And thank you for
letting me come talk to you about monsters
and hopefully talking back to me about monsters
as well. I hope we've got some time.
I'm planning for some time for Q and A so
anything I don't cover in the discussion can
I hopefully answer for
you. So this is a weird book in certain kinds
of ways.
This is a book that's a weird combination
of some
different things. I am a historian. I'm a
traditionally
trained historian even if I'm not a traditional
historian
in some ways. And so, this book really is
a cultural
history of the idea of the monster. It's not
history of horror movies although there's
a lot of horror
movies in it. It's a cultural history of how
narratives
of monsters have intersected with American
history from
the colonial -- first period of colonial settlement
all
the way to the present. So that's part of
it. Part of
what makes it weird -- if that's not weird
enough to try
to do that -- is that this is also a book
written by and
for horror nerds. [audience chuckles] I am
absolutely a horror geek. I
consider myself kind of part of that community.
I see
this book in a way as a kind of valentine
to the genre
that I love so much. And that kind of community
that
gathers around it. So, you know, it's -- it's
a book
that is different things. It has sort of an
underlying
seriousness. You'll find phrases in there
like
'landscapes of corpses' [laughter] and that
kind of thing that
suggests, in fact, I really am after exploring
some of the
darker parts of American history. But then,
I think also
horror fans will find a lot in it as well.
Hopefully
finding ways to look at layers of the kind
of pop culture
entertainment they already enjoy and encounter
those
things in a different kind of way. Now, as
Shannon
mentioned, I do, in fact, owe -- blame -- whatever
part of
this fascination to a lifelong fascination
with classic
horror and also more contemporary horror.
The fact of
the matter is, I spent a number of long Saturday
afternoons in the late
70s -- I've told my college kids before during
the
Clinton years but in fact it was during the
Carter years. [laughter]
Sitting down in front of my parents ginormous
console
television set which I also have to explain
to them
didn't mean it was a wide screen TV. [laughter]
It means it was
this gigantic piece of furniture with this
little tiny
screen on it watching shock theater. If you're
not
familiar with shock theater. Shock was actually
a
package of films that Universal Studios started
marketing
in the late 1950s to local TV stations. And
they
actually marketed two packages -- one that
was called
Shock Theatre, the second that was called
Son of Shock.
And it actually was this combination of kind
of the
universal monsters -- Bride of Frankenstein,
Frankenstein, Dracula, Wolfman,
all that kind of stuff along with the 1950's
creature
features. The giant bugs. The 50-foot women.
All
of those kind of radioactive terrors that
were very much
part of the Cold War mentality in America.
And so, you
know, for me in a sense that's kind of where
my own
obsessions along those kinds of lines began.
Now, the
question though becomes, "Fine, okay. We get
it, Poole.
You're a weird kid. [audience laughs] There's
no doubt about that. But
how does that connect to serious historical
work?" And
is that kind of material serious enough for
real
historical inquiry?" Well, I think that it
is. And I
think it is, in part, because of what one
of my favorite
historians -- who's not actually a historian
-- Greil
Marcus -- has to say. A quote that in some
ways --
you'll find it in the book -- but it's really
informative
about what I explore. [reading] "Parts of
history, he says, because they
don't fit the story a people wants to tell
itself,
survive only as haunts and as fairy tales."
So there is
as with every country and as with every society
and every
culture, there's this master narrative. There's
this
story that we get out of the textbooks. There's
the
story that the guy up in front of the classroom
in the
tie tells us. There's the chronology that
we're taught
to believe is essentially the story of American
history
or the story of any culture for that matter.
But most of
us have the sense that there's something lying
underneath. Something's under the bed. Something's
hiding in the closet. There's something in
kind of the
darkest part of the forest. And that's why
I see
monsters as a kind of access point into secret
histories.
And I'm almost afraid to use that term, because
you know
now there's sort of the secret history of
everything.
But I think when it comes to exploring the
master
narratives -- particularly of history that
we've been
told to accept--, it's an important idea.
And I think that
monsters have become -- as I've explained
in other
contexts -- a kind of a map to hidden topographies.
A
map to where the bodies are buried in American
history.
Now, in the book, I don't actually give a
definition of
the monster. I don't actually say, "Monsters
are this."
There's a lot of different reasons for that.
Partially because
monsters today are all different sorts of
things. But I
think also it's because what the monster is
depends on
the historical context that they emerge in.
Monsters
actually kind of soak up meaning. They're
sort of these
sponges that collect meaning out of the historical
context in which they appear. So, for example,
when I
talk with my college students about the universal
monster
cycle -- Dracula, wolf man etcetera. They,
almost the
first thing they always say is, "you know,
that stuff
just isn't scary. How could people have thought
that
that was scary?" Even more interesting I've
had the
experience of watching the exorcist with graduate
students -- which I and even some of you still
find a
frightening film -- and their response has
been, "you
know, I just don't get it. This is too slow.
The
special effects aren't that great. I just
really don't
find it frightening." Well, I think the fact
of the
matter is, that different things are frightening
at
different periods and they're frightening
because of the
context they're in. They're frightening because
they're
kind of sticking in and playing around with
parts of others
that are connected to that larger cultural
aegis.
They're kind of soaking up meaning while at
the very same time
they're these powerful social constructions
-- monsters
are -- all by themselves kind of helping to
contribute
meaning in certain kinds of ways to the era
that they
appear in. That's a little abstract. So let's
talk
about a couple of very specific examples that
I think
will help you see this. And what I've decided
I'll talk
about today is first of all the 19th century
American
obsession with the sea serpent. You may not
know that
there was a 19th century American obsession
with the sea
serpent, [audience chuckles] but after today
you will be aware how obsessed
Americans were with this creature and then
something that
you probably know a good bit more about. That
is the
obsession with the serial killer and with
the slasher.
Kind of the murdering maniac, hook for a hand.
All that
kind of stuff from the 70s and 80s. So kind
of a more
historical example -- the way we tend to think
about that
term -- and then a more contemporary one.
But let's get
to the sea serpent first. Indeed, Americans
were
obsessed with this creature in the 19th century.
And
when I say "obsessed," I don't just mean as
a pop culture
phenomenon. I don't just mean that there were
sort of
marginal people in American society who were
interested
in the possibility of these creatures. I actually
mean
that, even in the emerging scientific community
in
America. Sort of the beginnings of natural
science.
There was a real interest in whether or not
sea serpents
were real. In fact, no less a scientific name
than
Charles Lyell the geologist was absolutely
convinced, based on
eyewitness accounts, that sea serpents were
an
undiscovered animal. A creature that we simply
didn't
have an exhibit or specimen of and that we
were
eventually going to find. Now, at least one
of -- and
this is not the only -- but one of kind of
the trigger
points for interest in this creature was a
series of
sightings not too far from here. In 1817,
there were a
series of sea serpent sightings in Gloucester
Harbor. In fact, hundreds of people claimed
that this creature, and they
actually drew a picture of it, this creature
showed
itself in the harbor. Was seen by whalers
who got out in
their row boats and went out to get it in
true American
style when they saw this marvel, they decided
"hey let's
get our harpoons and our muskets and let's
go kill it." [laughter]
And so, hundreds as you can see here -- well,
make you
can't see it very well -- but it's the largest
ever seen
in America. Just made its appearance in Gloucester
Harbor, Cape Ann,
and has been seen by hundreds of respectable
citizens,
people claim. Not a bunch of crazies. Not
slack jawed
yokels and that kind of thing. Hundreds of
respectable citizens saw this
creature, it was claimed. Now, there was so
much interest
in this that an early American scientific
society -- in
fact a very elite scientific society -- known
as the New England Linnaean Society, located
in Boston featuring a number of kind of America's
emerging scientific elite. They took a special
interest
in the sea serpent, decided they were going
to work up a
zoological profile of it. Started collecting
a variety
of eyewitness accounts including the eye witness
accounts that came from the Gloucester Harbor
siting. And then at one point, actually believed
they had
found a specimen. And here's a drawing of
it that a
member of the society did. Thought that they
had found a
specimen of one of the sea serpent's babies
-- one of its
spawn essentially -- about three feet in length.
And
there had actually been a lot of discussion
about the
spawn of the sea serpent. There was all this
talk in
1817, 1818 -- well, maybe this thing has shown
up in
Gloucester Harbor because it's going to spawn
and that's
going to be really terrible for the fishing
industry. They
were taking it this seriously they thought
how is this
monster going to ruin the local economy was
the
discussion. Well, the Linnaean Society found
this
creature -- three feet long -- very strange
markings on
it. They could not identify it as any known
zoological
specimen. Unfortunately for them but good
for science,
Louis Agassiz famous zoologist connected to
Harvard took
a look at at it and said, "you know, this
isn't actually
a spawn of a sea serpent. This is actually
a fairly
common New England water snake that happens
to have a skin disease, some kind of skin
infection that has caused it to have all these
strange
markings." New England Linnaean Society disappeared
about two years later. Essentially in kind
of complete
embarrassment. They only formed in 1818, so
they weren't
around that long. There were other reasons
for their
dissolution, but I think this was part of
it. So after
this, the scientific or emerging professionalized
scientific community in America sort of takes
a turn when
it comes to the sea serpent. They start saying
things
like eyewitness accounts are not enough. That's
not what
we mean by scientific evidence. Scientific
evidence has
to do with having a specimen in a lab that
is confirmed.
Doesn't have to do with how many people have
seen it.
And the American public's response to this
was, "Well,
okay, fine. But sea serpents are awesome.
And what if
they do exist?" [laughter] And so, the sea
serpent becomes a really
important part of American popular culture.
As you can
see here. This is from the 1850s. This is
a piece of
sheet music from the 1850s. Sort of the 19th
century
version of the CD or the download. And I actually
discovered
in an issue of Harper's Magazine that this
particular
sheet music was on whoever was the 1850s version
of Ryan Seacrest's top
ten list of best-selling sheet music. So the
Sea Serpent
Polka. Very, very popular. Captains started
naming their
ships the USS Sea Serpent. It just became
a very important
part of American culture and representation.
It even
showed up in the side show and sort of the
history -- the
emerging history of the American carnival
tradition. And
I wanted to show you this image, in part,
because you can
see where this is going and you can see where
the turn
away from science fits in with this. This
great wonder
of the world -- Hydrarchos -- sea serpent.
Supposedly 114
feet in length. This traveled all over the
country.
This is actually from an advertisement for
a show in
Brooklyn. And unfortunately you can't see
the small
print in there. You can see it in the book.
The image
is reproduced in the book. But it essentially
makes the
claim not that this is an unknown animal,
not that this is an animal we haven't
discovered yet, but rather that it is a supernatural
creature.
In fact, it specifically says -- the promoter
claimed -- what we've got here is the skeleton
of
Leviathan. This beast from the Hebrew Bible.
From the
Old Testament this kind of chaos monster that
existed
from the beginning of time. So you see there,
as the scientific community has
said, "no, we need evidence." Sort of the
American
public in the popular imagination said, "We
don't care about that
and in fact, maybe it's supernatural. Maybe
that's the
explanation for these creatures." As you might
guess, I
do draw some connections in the book between
sort of
popular misunderstanding of what counts for
scientific
evidence today -- the whole debate over intelligent
design. I mean in certain kinds of ways, it's
the same
sort of discussion. By the way, just side
note, that in
fact was an actual set of fossils. It's simply
that it
was fossils that had been taxidermied together
to look like a
sea serpent and became so popular that Herman
Melville
actually mentions it in Moby Dick. There's
a reference in
Moby Dick to these fossils that have been
discovered in
northern Alabama that some people believe
are the bones
of fallen angels, he says. Became quite a
important part
of sort of the American psyche in the 19th
century. Now,
not all monsters are quite so friendly and
interesting as
the sea serpent. And in fact in some ways
at least one
of the new monsters -- the late 20th century
monsters --
that have obsessed Americans is sort of the
knife-wielding maniac. The psycho. And of
course, this
begins in the late 1950s with one of America's
first
modern celebrity serial killers -- Ed Gein.
The Ed Gein
killings which directly influenced the 1960
film Psycho.
And then, by the 1970s, certainly by the 1980s
and for
sure in the early 90s, there was this mountain
of films,
books, sociological material, even criminological
material on the dangers of the serial killer.
And in
fact, the alleged dangers of the serial killer
to
essentially everybody. To every American.
Even though
statistically, all the homicides in the United
States
during the 1980s taken together -- only about
0.01
percent of those murders were actually ever
traced to an
actual serial killer or stranger killing as
they were
often called. And yet, there was this mountain
of
material produced about them. Why is that?
Why did the
serial killer become the monster of that particular
moment? Well, I think there's a number of
answers to
that. And part of it has to do with the sort
of
political climate during that period. There
were some
who made a connection -- kind of a direct
connection --
between what they saw as the changes to American
society
during the sexual revolution. During the 1960s
and
counterculture and what they saw as an increasingly
quote
unquote degenerate society in the 1970s and
1980s. And
some of these claims actually came from some
relatively
surprising sources. So, for example, in 1984
-- which
was kind of the beginning really in a way
of the serial
killer becoming a major obsession in American
society. A
New York Times Editorial reported that quote
many
officials -- no officials named, no agency
actually
linked to them, just simply "many officials,"
believe
that a link exists between sweeping changes
and attitudes
regarding sexuality that have occurred in
the last 20
years and the emergence of the serial killer.
So that
very vague assertion suggested that the sexual
revolution -- maybe second wave feminism as
well -- the
direct result of that had been serial murder.
Now, some
made this -- connected these dots -- dots
not easy to
connect in an even stranger sort of way. One
of the most
popular genres during the 1980s and in fact
it's remained
a very popular genre -- true crime book, the
true crime novel. And in fact, there
was a particular author, Ann Rule, R-U-L-E,
who was a particular best seller.
I mean, her books were just insanely popular.
If there
are any -- this is a strange way to put it
-- but if
there are any Ted Bundy fans [laughter] out
there. Then [chuckles] you
probably have heard the name Ann Rule. Because
she wrote
the book "Stranger Beside Me," which has become
classic
in the true crime genre. Now Ann Rule is an
interesting
person. She actually got her start during
the 1960s
writing these kind of under-the-counter -- literally
kept
under the counter-- magazines with names like
Spicy
Detective. True Crime. That kind of stuff.
And yet,
by the 80s, she's a best-selling author and
she's writing
for magazines like Good Housekeeping and Family
Circle.
And she's making claims like these. In her
book about
Ted Bundy, she suggests part of the reason
that Bundy becomes a
serial killer is that he came from an unstable
home. An
unstable domestic environment. She says and
I quote,
"his mother was deeply involved in the promiscuous
culture created by the 1960s." And so, her
equation
there is "single mom; dates a lot -- Ted Bundy."
[laughter] Now obviously this was sort of
a -- these
were sub-political kinds of statements. She
was not
openly allying herself with the emerging Christian
right,
which it's no accident I think the Moral Majority
was
formed in 1978 almost on the emergence of
this serial
killer epidemic quote unquote. Nevertheless,
she is using a kind
of political language -- certainly a culturally
political
language. And she wasn't alone in this. The
true crime
genre did this a lot, talked about the monster
as really the production or
the produce of the counterculture. Now, part
of this
era -- part of the era of the 1980s and part
of really
the American fascination with the serial killer--
was the
emergence of the popularity of the slasher
film. Now,
there's a whole political discussion around
the slasher
film that I get into in the book that I won't
really get
into here. The really short version of it
was that at
least part of the critique of the slasher
film was from
second wave feminist critics who argued that
essentially
these are movies are killing women. These
are movies
about how the sexual revolution was bad. These
are
movies in which the first couple that had
sex is the one
that dies and the only woman that lives is
the one that's
a virgin. That's kind of really in a way I
would argue a
simplistic understanding of these films. And
that did
come out of and was important part of second
wave feminism's
critique of these. Third wave feminism has
a much more
complicated view of these movies. And I should
add even
in talking about this that I consider myself
a feminist
scholar. And so, some of the things I'll have
to say about
them should be read in that light. I actually
want to
bracket that whole discussion -- although
I'm happy to
answer some questions about it and talk to
you instead a
little bit about kind of a different -- maybe
a sort of
new interpretation of these films. I actually
see the
slasher films as what I call subversive fairy
tales.
Stories that are overturning certain kinds
of stories
that had already been circulating in American
society.
Specifically, cautionary tales about the dangers
of the
counterculture, the dangers of sexuality.
Urban legends
and social rumors that had suggested basically
young
people -- particularly young women -- were
completely out
of control. So let me give you a couple of
examples of
that. In talking about what I call the dangerous
babysitter stories. And then, also the babysitters
in
danger stories. Let's talk dangerous babysitters
first.
Now, believe me I didn't think that a book
about monsters
would lead me into researching the history
of babysitting but it
certainly did and it actually turned out to
be a
important part of this story. You probably
all heard the
urban legend of the cooked baby. The cooked
baby story
as it's generally told today. Although this
isn't the
original version of it. I'll tell you the
original
version. But as it's usually told today. Babysitter
--
she's talking to -- who of course is female,
right?
Always female. Babysitter is talking on her
phone to her
boyfriend. She's watching TV. She's raiding
the
refrigerator. She's been told to put the roast
in the
oven and the baby to bed and [laughter] instead
she puts, you know,
the roast to bed and she puts the baby in
the oven. It's
terrible, right? And everybody knows somebody
who knows
somebody who's cousin knew somebody that saw
this on the
news. [laughter] It's an urban legend, right?
Well, the original
version of this story -- folklorists refer
to it as the
hippie babysitter. Because it's a story that
started
circulating in the 1960s. And it basically
went like
this. It's similar to the version I just repeated,
except the babysitter is a counter-cultural
teen that
shows up high. And for whatever reason -- parents
decide, "okay, she's high. We're going out
to dinner
anyway." They leave her with the baby. And
because
she's smoking pot, that has led her to put
the roast to
bed and the baby in the oven. Now, there's
an even later
version of the story that started making the
rounds in
the 1970s that made it not a babysitter but
rather a
single mom who's taken too much Valium. And
that's
what caused this horrible thing to occur.
So these
were -- these were sort of social cautionary
tales.
These kind of social rumors that were meant
to be
warnings about what happens if you trust young
people, if
you let counter-cultural kids too close to
your own kids,
and about why you ought to, for goodness sakes,
stay within
a traditional marriage. You're liable to cook
the baby
otherwise essentially. [laughter] Now, allied
to those stories is
the babysitter in danger story. And this is
so famous, I
don't even have to tell it. In fact, there
was a movie
made about it in the 70s and a recent remake.
The whole
story about the babysitter. She's at home.
There's a
call being made. The call, it turns out, is
from inside
the house. The mad killer is actually up stairs.
It is
sometimes called the story of the man upstairs.
That's
sort of the folklorist version of it. It's
related to
the dangerous babysitter in that it's yet
another story
about how, really, young women don't know
what they're
doing. They really cannot be left in charge
of things.
They're going to be -- they're going to become
victims.
And both of these versions -- both of these
types of
stories -- either say young women are victimizers
or
they're victims. Now, what does that have
to do with the
Slasher genre? Well, the Slasher genre in
different ways
turns these stories on their heads. It takes
these
social cautionary tales, which have basically
been around
for 20 years, and tells a very different version
of them.
John Carpenter's Halloween, for example, in
1978, it's a story about babysitters
in danger. Laurie Strode is a babysitter in
danger. Jamie Leigh
Curtis is a babysitter in danger. Does she
become the
victim? Does she show herself ultimately to
be
irresponsible? No. In fact, she becomes the
monster
hunter. She's kind of the Van Helsing of the
story -- the one that
kills the monster at least until the sequel.
And of
course they didn't know there was going to
be a sequel
when Halloween first came along. So for all
practical
purposes, the monster was dead. Now, quickly
-- there is
a related sort of genre of these. Related
to the
American summer camp. And again, as with babysitting,
I
really didn't think examining monsters was
going to end
up leading me to examine the history of the
American
summer camp, but it certainly did. And let
me give you
kind of a brief version of that. After World
War II, the
summer camp becomes very important, as does
a whole
network really of civic organizations, church
groups,
neighborhood organizations, sports organizations
-- all
which had the purpose of kind of reining in
young people
who were increasingly seen as getting totally
out of
control. We think of that as, "That's a 1960s
phenomenon," but it's not. 1950s was the age
of Marlon
Brando and the Wild Ones; nobody wanted their
kid to be Marlon Brando. It's the age of "Rebel
Without a Cause."
Everybody's afraid, "my kid -- he's wearing
a leather
jacket; he's going to turn out to be James
Dean." It
was the age of the juvenile delinquent . The
idea of the
juvenile delinquent became important. So there's
the
emergence of all this whole system of things
meant to
become sites of social discipline. Meant to
turn kids
into good citizens, basically. And the summer
camp was
very much a part of that. Now, a very strange
side to
summer camp, which we think of as, you know,
encouraging
the values of teamwork. Everybody sits around
the
campfire and sings the praises of Camp Watchatoochee
--
whatever it happens to be. Kids go out and
they encounter
nature. Fresh air. Exercise. Blah, blah, blah.
That's
what it's supposed to be about. And yet, there's
this
other side to the summer camp, which many
of you are
probably familiar with -- in which sitting
around the
campfire also means hearing stories of monstrous
murdering maniacs [laughter] who are hiding
in the woods, [laughter] hiding in
the darkness just right beyond the light of
the campfire.
The escaped lunatic with a hook for a hand
-- which by
the way, lunatics who have lost their hands.
Why give
them a hook? [laughter] Ever thought about
that? Doesn't make
rational sense. Not a hook. Worst idea ever.
And yet,
almost every camp -- and actually examined
kind of the
alumni memories and this kind of thing of
camps all over
the country. And what I found was camps in
central
Kentucky had stories of Headless Hattie. This
horrible
sort of female demonic presence that was going
to come
after the kids. I learned about -- some of
you maybe
have seen the documentary about "Cropsey",
this disfigured hermit in
Staten Island but also camps around upstate
New York. And the
warnings always were, "it's the kids who aren't
practicing the values being taught at summer
camp that
the creature is going to get." So, if you're
the kid
smoking pot out in the woods, then Headless
Hattie is
going to get you. If you're the kid who's
off by
themselves instead of swimming and doing archery
practice
and that kind of stuff, then that's going
to make you the
victim. In the strangest -- in a way most
offensive
thing I've found-- was from one of these upstate
New York
camps that kind of emphasize that it's the
kids who don't
follow the fresh air, physical regime aspect
of summer
camp that the monster gets. In fact, the specific
quote -- and I am quoting here -- was that
"we learned
that Cropsey always goes after the fat kids"
unquote. So
it's literally the kids that are physically
unfit that
aren't living up to this sort of standard
of health and
good citizenship that the monster is going
to go after.
Well, this is part of what makes Friday the
13th -- at
least in its first two versions -- so interesting.
You
think, "well, it actually sounds very similar.
There's a
summer camp. There's a maniac out in the woods
surrounding
the summer camp. But guess what? He doesn't
go after
the kids. He goes after the counselors. And
in fact, he
goes after the counselors who are telling
the stories
around the campfire of the thing that is going
to to get
you. So in a certain kind of sense, the Friday
the 13th
films -- particularly again the early ones
-- I'm talking
1981, 1982, become sort of these vengeance
narratives
for kids who had sort of heard this stuff
from counselors
for ten years, for 20 years, the monster becomes
not a moral
custodian, but rather just this force that's
going to
wreak vengeance on all these forces of control
that
they've had to encounter at summer camp and
in other
kinds of situations. I would add really briefly
that at
least part of my response to kind of the political
discussion around the Slasher film has to
do with the
birth of the idea of the final girl, which
is not my
phrase at all. There's a scholar by the name
of Carol
Clover who wrote this book with this great
title called
Men, Women and Chain Saws [laughter] in which
--she as a feminist
scholar herself-- as well explores these films
and talks
about the fact that -- first of all, they're
not simply
about women being killed, they're about women
fighting
killers. And in fact, Halloween, which you
see here with
Jamie Lee Curtis as we've already talked about.
That's
the story. And I actually think a lot of these
films
are the background to a figure that's now
essentially ubiquitous
in popular culture -- the idea of the female
action hero,
which Buffy is part of, but you could name
ten other
examples in many kinds of ways. That doesn't
make them
feminist films, but also problematizes the
idea that
they're simply films about killing women.
You could make
a stronger argument that they're about women
killing
monsters. Which is also an interesting kind
of, part
of a discussion given the political climate
of the 1970s
and 80s when these films were born. So, just
to wrap up
and to hopefully give us a bit of time for
questions as
well, I just like to say that part of what
my analysis
does and what the book tries to do is to make
the
argument that really story and history are
not separate.
It's not that monsters are about popular entertainment
that's here. And then actual events -- the
events that
people are actually living as history are
over here.
Narrative and social structure are always
together. Now,
we tend to pull them apart. I guess I've pulled
them
apart today just kind of for purposes of analysis.
I'm
not sure that that's how people actually experience
the
world though. I think that the images that
they see in
popular narratives -- whether that's more
recently in
film or longer ago in discussions about sightings
of the
sea serpent -- has a lot to do with how they
experience
history. And so, then the monster becomes
not just a
sort of marginalized entertainment or interesting
pop
culture, it does become this guide into this
underground
America -- a way for us to go places that
maybe there's
not any other way for us to go. So thank you
very much.
And if you have any questions or anything
you'd like to
talk about. Thank you.
[Applause].
>>Scott: Any more of this you'd like to talk
about, I'd love to.
>> Male #1: Could you talk about what's happened
to vampires in the last 20 years?
[laughter]
>> Scott: Oh gosh. In fact, interviewer a
couple of weeks ago
asked me a interesting question. "if you could
re-title
your book, what would you re-title it?" And
I've not
seriously answered. I think I would call it,
"yes, there
is stuff about vampires and zombies in here."
[laughter] Because
you're definitely not the first person. I
actually spent
a whole chapter on this. A chapter entitled
"Undead
Americans," in which I explore -- not just
the recent --
certainly not the recent interest in vampires
and zombies
as well. But the fact that that's part of
a longer
trajectory. Really kind of going back to the
1970s in
certain kinds of ways. In fact, although I'm
not going
to blame Anne Rice for Twilight. Not at all.
I do think
kind of this image of the tormented brooding
vampire with
a soul, who wants a soul, and also in love,
[laughter] and that kind of
thing. I mean, that really goes back to -- that
really
goes back to the incredibly popular Anne Rice
novels which
were 1970s. Came out of the 1970s. And is
part of --
both that and the zombie phenomenon. I see
as part of
kind of a -- well, actually I talk about Reagan
talking
about the post-Vietnam syndrome, which, in
part, has to do
with a fascination with and an awareness of
the
dismembered body. Gore as kind of a popular
culture in
certain ways obviously more of an influence
on the zombie
mythology than vampire but certainly kind
of a
fascination with death that's very much in
the
background. Yeah.
>> Male #2: Regarding the serial killer fascination.
[inaudible]
Jack the Ripper. [inaudible] Like the time
where people sensationalize.
>> Scott: Oh, actually in the 1880s. One of
the most popular American -- not English --
American narratives was Jack the Ripper.
Americans were more into Jack the Ripper than
the British were. In fact, so much so there
were all these claims Jack the Ripper was
an
American. There were claims that Jack the
Ripper -- [audience member comments inaudibly]
[laughter] It's hilarious. Because
actually that's exactly what it was. It was
kind of like this. [laughter] Their monster
can't be
better than our monster, you know? [laughter]
It's
exactly it. I mean, there were stories
about -- oh, there's been these weird killings
in Texas -- got to be Jack the Ripper. Weird
killings in New York. He's come over here
or
maybe he was an American in the first place.
There were novels written in which the
Pinkerton agents, that sort of secret service
--
private secret service, pre-Black Water Black
Water of the 19th century they go over to
England to investigate the White Chapel murders
and they discover it's actually a Native
American who's doing this and that that
accounts for the quote unquote savagery of
the killings. And
so, yeah. Many of you if you've ever read
Larson's excellent book, "Devil in a White
City." That talks about the serial killer,
H. H.
Holmes, who in some ways was kind of America's
first real celebrity serial killer of the
19th
century. In fact, received like 10,000 bucks
from Hearst to write his story. It was kind
of
the first true crime story. Then it went away.
For a really long time. And comes back. But
there's definitely a big background. I wish
I
had put that in the book "USA, USA". [laughter]
That would
have been a great section title kind of for
that really..
>> Male #3: So earlier you were talking about
how they watch these movies -- shock movies.
And you said that it was basically the culture
at the time didn't find this scary. Could
it
also be these things have been subsumed into
the culture. They've seen these things before
so it no longer -- like out there and scary.
>> Scott: I think that could be it. I think
that, you know -- so for example, you know,
thinking about -- thinking about the
universal -- the universal monsters. They're
in some ways almost a kind of an iconography
now. And kind of immediately recognizable.
You know, I thought of them before as kind
of
an almost literal iconography in the sense
that
religious symbols that at one time may have
had
this powerful "oomph" kind of punch. You know,
even -- especially some of the gory stuff
like
stations of the cross and saints with arrows
sticking out of them and all that kind of
thing. I mean, after a certain point, that
just becomes that stuff on the church wall.
And I think in a certain kind of way, that
maybe has happened with those kinds of
monsters. Although, I do still think that
it
has to do with the moment that makes things
scary. I mean, I think it's really interesting
for example that what's sometimes called the
torture porn genre -- The Hostel and Saw and
that kind of stuff. I mean, those movies
appear right in a moment when we're having
an actual
conversation about the ethics of torture.
And
so, it seems like the monsters are really
hard
wired into the moment in a way that makes
them
frightening. Which means that horror is a
historical experience, you know, in a kind
of
way.
>> Male #4: Along those same lines, what are
your thoughts about Colonial New England and
kind of unique
circumstances then, whether it's sea serpents
on Gloucester or the Salem witch trials, what
was going on in this part of the country that
caused so much of it to happen here?
>> Scott: That's easy. Puritans. [laughter]
No, yeah --
in a way that's true. Actually, the first
sea
serpent sightings in New England were in the
early 17th century. Although the Gloucester
serpent that I talked about. There was a lot
of discussion about what that meant and even
some efforts later to connect it to the
supernatural. The very first sightings by
Puritans in 1630s, 1640s, they were convinced
these were manifestations of Satan. Big
surprise with them, right? Because everything
was. These were people who even thought black
bears were manifestation. Black dogs were
manifestations of the devil. And so, it's
really interesting that you move from that
to
-- in the very same part of the country -- in
the early 19th century -- a kind of quasi,
turned out
pseudo, kind of discussion of the same kinds
of
creatures. But yeah, it's certainly the
influence of Puritanism seeing all kinds of
phenomenon through the filter of Calvinism
and
all its associated terrors, you know? Yeah?
>> Female #1: Fascinating to think about the
path
of social discussion next to what's happening
in pop culture. Just curious
think about today and monsters in the news
today of the history
or even broader catholic church to Penn State.
It's the national
social dialogue that you would kind of think
was running in parallel to that-- experience,
if there is one.
>> Scott: Well, you know, there actually is
always -- always -- horror narratives connected
to dangers to children. And that is nothing
new at all. I mean, in fact, the Slasher
phenomenon, the serial killer phenomenon,
was
connected to that. The witch craze was connected
to
that to some degree. Because there were all
these discussions about, "it's women who are
infertile, who are unable to become mothers
who
are the ones most likely to become witches."
And that's kind of an anxiety about, "what's
happening with the children?" Yeah, I think
sort of -- a good example of this in the 1980s,
we had the missing child panic in the 1980s.
Even though statistically there were actually
fewer missing children during that era than
in
earlier kinds of eras. But it all got tied
into -- not just the serial killer panic -- you
mention my Satan In America book for example.
I talk about the Satanic panic of that era
where, you know, there was this whole
discussion of every time somebody's pet went
missing, they were convinced there was a
Satanic ceremony of some kind being performed.
My grandmother
actually thought Satanists were stealing her
cats. [laughter] Serious..
>>Male #5: Have we seen changes in like the
tenor or the subjects of the monster
over the years, sort of like the waves of
immigration that we've seen?
>> Scott: Yes, although what came to mind
when
you first said that was that there's been
a
tendency obviously through American history
to
monsterrize the immigrant in certain kinds
of
ways. I actually think that that's one of
the
interesting things about the popularity of
Dracula in 1931. Dracula is essentially an
immigrant. And in fact, he's an eastern
European immigrant, which American culture
during that period was especially nervous
about. People with Bela Lugosi's accent were
seen as a threat. And a specific kind of
threat. Don't know if you're familiar with
the white slavery panic of the early 20th
century. This is what it was called. This
kind of rumor panic that essentially said,
"you
know, these young innocent Anglo women from
the
farms of the Midwest are going to places like
Chicago. And what they're finding there are
these immigrants from eastern Europe, often
Jews, who are seducing them, turning them
into
prostitutes." Sort of early ideas about sex
traffic about. That kind of stuff. Never any
actual evidence that this was actually
happening, as with most of these things. There
were novels being published
about it, discussions of it. Then you have
the very same period Dracula that's about
this
eastern European immigrant who has this
incredible power to seduce women with a simple
look and to actually kind of make them part
of
his harem. And so, again, I think that kind
goes to this idea of, "what is it about history
that makes things frightening at particular
moments?" I mean, in the background of those
people's minds would have been all of those
ideas.
Whether or not it was sort of conscious when
they were watching it is hard to know. I've
also thought about the fact today when we
watch
the original Frankenstein, James Whale's 1932
Frankenstein. He comes across.
And I think this was actually Whale's intention.
He comes across as this very sympathetic kind
of monster. I'm not sure many 1932 audiences
would have seen it that way. You know, there's
kind of a lynch mob that forms in Frankenstein.
The whole angry villagers with torches kind
of
stuff. And they form because he essentially
kills this young girl. It's an accident, but
he kills her anyway. One of the things that
struck me as I was reading and writing about
that was, you
know, in 1932, film that showed all over the
country, film that also showed in rural
theaters in the American South, there would
have been people -- I don't mean this as a
joke
at all -- there would have been people watching
that film who had taken part in a lynch mob.
I
mean, lynching was relatively common during
that
period in the South. And so, how they would
have viewed that story as opposed to how
contemporary viewers would have seen it is
an
interesting thing to look at it. I mean, some
of the same people would have thrilled to
the heroics of the
Ku Klux Klan in Birth of a Nation, right.
And there's
actually similar imagery in Frankenstein and
Birth of a Nation. And
so, I think in a way history is what's scary.
It's what's happening at that particular
historical moment.
>> Male #6: When you're talking about history
is
what's scary. If you look at how things have
progressed.
These supernatural creatures and
then there's Satanism and there's magic and
supernatural. And I'm looking at movies now
--
particularly the Saw genre. Are people scared
of mechanical engineers? [laughter]
>> Scott: Yes. [laughter] People are also
increasingly scared -- you know, historians
aren't really supposed to prognosticate, but
people are also increasingly scared of sort
of
the terrors of the digital frontier. This
may
be a good place to talk about this. You know,
I think about films like Source Code, Duncan
Jones' Source Code, where
there's this idea of -- it's not killer
Androids -- it's not killer robots. It's our
humanity locked into the technology. And also,
the terrors that I think are kind of implicit
in the fact that, almost all of us exist as
ourselves and also as Internet constructs
of
one kind or another. I mean, my publicist
made me get on Twitter this month. Been on
Facebook forever. So now there's me. But then
there's also these things that aren't really
me
out there, you know? And what's that? That's
the doppelganger. I mean, that's sort of the
terror
as old as Gothic literature itself. Things
that are you but really isn't you. And I
actually think that in film and maybe even
in
ethical reflection on these kinds of things,
we're going to see more and more monsters
on
that digital frontier. Let's call them the
Google monsters for example. [laughter] Yeah?
>> Male #7: In 9/11 something very, very scary
happened. And we sort of started a national
conversation
about fear became 'we have to protect ourselves
from fear' -- we're being too driven by
fear. We need to be driven by hope. All these
things. And I [inaudible] on that translating
itself to
monsters in the pop culture over the last
10 years. Is it because it
was all above board that there wasn't any
need to create things below board? Or [inaudible].
>> Male #8: That's like when the Muslim
subculture, the Arab terrorism started being
very big. That's the fear of where that fear
really started growing. It wasn't a big thing
before that. Before that when you heard about
people terrorism, they were blowing buses
up in London and the IRA?
>>Male #7: So I'm so close to it that the
fear
that sounds credible, although overblown to
me,
is what historians 50 years from now will
be
studying as the Muslim scare.
>> Scott: Yeah, I think there will be some
of
that. I think it's also true though that
and I think part of your question was, "why
haven't there been fantasy scenarios that
have
obstructed that, reflected that, become
metaphors of that." And I actually think there
has been to some degree. I actually think
that
part of the new terror of Contagion -- the
movie, Contagion -- the terror of infection.
The terror of sort of out of control disease
--
has to do with anxieties about everything
from
dirty bombs to bird flu to bio-weapons to
-- all
of that. And if you think about films like
Contagion, if you think about Rise of the
Planet of the Apes. If you think about 28
days
Later. I mean, all of these are films that
are
in certain kinds of ways tapping into fears
of
uncontrollable outbreaks of infection sometimes
related to military -- quasi military --
actions of one kind or another. I haven't
seen
Contagion yet, but I have a friend, horror
novelist Jonathan Maberry who said after he
saw Contagion, he wanted to do Jell-O shots
of
sanitary soap. [laughter] So I don't know
if any of the
rest of you have seen it yet, but anyway.
Yeah?
>> Male #9: Potential source just like much
of
the TV series 24 particularly [audience members
speak simultaneously] --
>>Male #10: There's a lot
of stuff I don't think it falls into the horror
of the genre. It falls into action adventure
more than horror.
>> Male #11: Well, so 24 is a great example.
I
think it is trying to look at it 40 years
later. The story of the pervasive underground
conspiracy. He has to not just find the first
guy. But the guy behind and the guy behind.
>> Scott: Right. And the threat that's being
faced is so terrible that any means necessary
becomes possible to deal with it is often
the case in
the horror genre. Like, if you're fighting
the
monster, then everything becomes fair. You
can
sort of suspend ethical reflection, and you
can just burn
the whole town down, right? All right.
>> Multiple audience members: Thank you.
>>>>Scott: Thank-you
[applause]